hello folks
and welcome to rational science
today we're going to be talking about
phonons
and whether they're rational okay
and so here's the question of the day
that i want to try to answer
for you to keep track and follow
my train of thought okay question of the
day
are pseudo and quasi particles
rational and there you see the criteria
for
irrationality that i'm going to use okay
and it's uh if you reify a concept you
turn it into something concrete and
think you're moving
something real around when all you're
moving is an abstract cons
concept okay like love
and i guess you turn it into a heart and
you begin to move the heart around
you're saying oh i'm moving love no no
you're moving your heart that's not love
love is something else
and that sort of thing okay um
and there are other criteria not having
definitions or using them in constitu
consistently okay uh the theory doesn't
follow from the assumptions
et cetera et cetera number main one is
going to be that first one refined
concepts
turning a concept into a physical object
and then
pretending to move it around okay
okay uh
let's go with uh this next one here
okay so uh what we were doing these last
uh
couple weeks is uh we're looking at how
the world
originated okay so let's do a little
review of that because it does lead into
what the subject of today and the
official
version today out there is that there
was a big bang
an explosion some 13.8 14 billion years
ago
and were it uh
grew into what you see there we're at
the
right side right hand side of that uh
spilled cup a cup that's
tilted on the ground you know okay so
uh what you see there are the time
slices as you look at it
okay as you look at this whole thing and
we're at the
uh right at the edge there of time which
is on the right hand side
okay so this is how they visualize the
mathematicians visualize this is the
explanation they give
the theory they have for how the
universe came to be in other words there
was a some kind of explosion
billions of years ago and that evolved
through all these little intermediate
steps that i covered the other day
and we ended up where we are today which
is you know the uh the universe we have
today with galaxies and stars and atoms
and so on
they claim it didn't start like that
those atoms were manufactured then we
went from there to
galaxies and eventually to stars and
etc okay so just have to look at the
previous videos to get an idea
of what these people are talking about
okay
um the
i covered a couple people who proposed
how the universe came in to be how
matter came in to be
from absolutely nothing okay
so that was the deal because in the case
of christianity you have god
you know making the universe he's
eternal but
in the case of mathematical physics they
get rid of god and they say the universe
kind of self kick-started and you say
how did it do that please give me an
explanation for
how matter came into existence by itself
and from nothing
er tricky isn't it okay so this is
uh what uh these two gentlemen
stephen hawking who's no longer around
with us and neil turek
his understudy i guess
i covered those uh the other day again
uh
i looked at astronomy magazine a uh
an article that was written about them
where they
testified essentially in 1999
uh about how the universe got started
and that's what we have today
so nothing has changed in 20 years okay
and essentially here's the essence of it
in in other words okay you've got that
cone there which is what you saw a
minute ago the big bang expanding etc
and time goes along the edge of the cone
and the input that hawking and turret
did
i put into this picture is that
it didn't really start out at a point
okay at a dot it started on a
little curve there as you can see on the
right hand side there
there's a little curve and they call it
the p instantan
okay uh p because they they say this is
what it
more or less looks like and instantan
is this pseudo quasi particle
uh from which everything started
and you say holy what do you mean by
that
how can something start from nothing
and the way they explained it is that
time does not go along the edge
of the cone in the case of the instanton
okay time is merged with
space and both of them go around as a
circle
all the way down to the bottom of the
instanton
okay and the instanton is rounded
so no matter how small you make your
circle
if that circle represents space and time
you have no origin to space and time
because a circle has no beginning or end
it just goes around and around
and around in circles like these people
did okay
so that's that's their notion of course
they don't have a physical
interpretation for that really what they
do is they say well we have a
mathematical equation
that uh describes
this and the notion behind it is that
there is no beginning to time because
it's merged with space
and it's represented by a circle which
has no beginning or
end and so those are the notions that's
how they introduce
the beginning of the universe from
nothing they call that nothing the
instantan
okay and the reporter asked him well
where did the instant
ton come from and says it in a the
answer that's an irrational question you
can't answer
you can't ask that questions it's
unscientific
okay so the buck stopped there okay and
um
and they said it's just the laws of the
universe that
created the instant time so where did
the laws come from they said well we
don't know how to create something from
nothing
that was their answer so after all that
work
we understood nothing we have no notion
of how something can come from nothing
it's just a lot of blah blah blah and
mathematical equations
and we have no idea what the mechanism
is okay so that's the issue
okay um
here's the uh uh another fella
who uh did not agree with him does not
agree he's still alive
andre lindy and he's uh russian he works
but he works at stamford uh
university he's a teacher there or
professor
and he said you know he doesn't know how
to create something from nothing he
thinks that's religion
sounds to him like religion no it's not
really a religion what it is as an
irrational
explanation because you you have no way
of rationalizing it you have no way of
visualizing the mechanism that's why
it's an irrational explanation
it becomes religion when you believe
that that's what happened
when that when you you take that as
proof or
to you that's the way things happen then
it becomes a religion because now you
believe that that's how it happened
but as long as you just explain i mean i
can explain
what these people did doesn't mean i
believe it and i'm just explaining and
you rash
i'm just giving you an irrational
explanation and that's
essentially what he's saying saying that
sounds a lot like an irrational
explanation
what does he propose instead he proposes
the multiverse he
says well there are all these universes
popping in and out of existence i guess
like bubbles out there uh
and that's his version of how the
universe
started ours is just one of the little
universes out there that
you know got kick-started somehow and
again he doesn't explain it because
he doesn't claim to have an explanation
uh of something from nothing so he
alludes that question altogether
okay this is uh just in case for
reference this is christianity's version
which is uh
god waving his magic wand according to
the bible just saying
abracadabra and the universe came to be
and god is
assumed to be eternal okay so god's
always been around
so no one created him and so we have
eternity creating uh
the temporal world okay i guess you
could say
okay so let's proceed here this is my
summary of what these people said again
i'm just
reviewing this okay uh the instantaneous
a pseudo particle
okay what is a pseudo particle is a
concept
that is uh halfway in the process of
morphing into a particle
okay it's not yet a particle it's a
pseudo but it's on its way it's halfway
between
being it's in a limbo somewhere between
being and not
that's that's what they're trying to
tell you it actually it's it's an
equation that's all it is
that they treat as a particle and it's
got to do with that word
particle because they use that word
but they don't mean it they don't mean
what we mean in physics by a
particle you mean like a you know like a
corpuscle
you know a little grain of sand uh
a little bead tiny bead that's a that's
a particle we understand that we all
understand that but when they say look
it's a particle and you say
what do you mean by a particle well it's
an equation
it's a probability function or a wave or
whatever
then you and then you start wondering
you know you're saying what do you mean
you call that a particle
why don't you call it a probability way
or uh
whatever an equation just call it an
equation a description
mathematical description that's what it
is that's not a particle
but that's where the they they
suggest they insinuate that they're
giving you a physical interpretation
because they use the word particle when
when you dig in there you find out that
the word particle is not
what you thought was a particle okay
same with spin by the way
they use the word spin they they talk
about spinning electrons etc etc
you say okay i understand all that turns
out they weren't talking about an
electron and they were not talking about
spin like you know when you spin the top
you know spin is something else
which they have not been able to define
now in
countless years okay so spin is not spin
so particles are not particle spins are
not spins
you got to be very careful with the
language in quantum mechanics
okay instantaneous a solution to an
equation that's what it is anton it's
just a solution
you know it's a number okay so
that's what an instantan is okay how a
solution to an equation becomes a
particle is a mystery
that no one will ever be able to explain
in a rational manner okay
so this so-called instantan pseudo
or quasi particle uh
no they cannot explain it they cannot
rationalize it okay
but you must pray to the instant on
because quantum says that it's the god
particle it's not the higgs the
god particle the god particle is the
instant time because that's when the
where from where the universe arose
when it was born father universe was
born in that little egg
that little p called the instantan okay
which is an equation that's a solution
whatever
everything started out at the big bang
uh
not at the big bang but at the instant
time big bang
is frame number two in the film that's
when the explosion occurs but before
that frame number one
these people at least were proposing was
the instant on and that's
essentially what all these
mathematicians believe okay that they
vouch for the instant on
because they use this term okay so it's
not like uh
it's not like nobody believes in this no
they do but
that's not what they tell the folks out
there because if they say
to the common man that everything
started from nothing and here's the
little p
called the instant on people gonna say
where did the p come from and they said
well that's him
you can't ask that question but it
started from nothing
okay the whole universe started from
nothing we caught the instant time but
don't ask where the instant time came
from that's more or less the answer
okay where all this uh came from again
i'm gonna
uh go quickly through this it's just uh
the chronology
uh mathematical chronology of how these
notions came to be okay and i'm gonna
skip some steps here
i'm just gonna say here was hamilton you
know and
he invented an incredible concept
stationary action
moving while standing still okay
playing baseball while being
uh you know fourth uh uh home
base or first base or whatever uh
they they have these two notions of
motion
uh static motion static dynamics
so to speak this uh
it's an oxymoron uh stationary action
what do you mean
stationary agnosis think and the way
it's done in mathematics again you have
to understand it's not
they're the physical notion they don't
care about that they care about the
mathematics of it
they say if you take the derivative of a
uh
an itinerary which is short enough which
is
uh in which there is very little to
no rate of change which is what a
derivative is you know it calculates the
rate of change if there's no rate of
change
what you get is zero so if you throw the
ball up in the air and it just stays
there for a second until it comes back
down
the moment it stays there okay you have
stationary motion because all you have
to do is take the derivative
of that no motion you could say and you
get a number it's
got to be zero because it's going to
come down there's no rate of change up
there
and that's more or less the notion
behind stationary
action okay uh try to visualize as best
as you can
it doesn't get any better than that okay
okay
from there you get people like
heisenberg okay and he came up with his
notion of
the uh principle of indeterminacy or
uncertainty principle whichever one you
want
and he said when the ball moves the ball
doesn't stand still and when the ball
stands still
it doesn't move he had this relation
between uh momentum and position he says
when you the more you know about one the
less you know about the other
no kidding yeah when i move i know very
little about standing still
and when i'm standing still completely
uh if i could you know completely still
like rigid like a stonewall you know
it's very hard to know how much i'm
moving
and you gotta know for this stuff okay
and again it all comes down to this
notion
of stationary action of mixing dynamics
with stat static okay
why did they have to do all this
nonsense well because they couldn't
explain action at a distance
so they had to describe it
mathematically
and the way you describe it
mathematically is the
uh and it has to do with the evolution
of quantum mechanics after world war
ii which is uh
you look at the paths and you say
look there's this motion okay but if you
take the derivative of that
of that itinerary and there's not enough
rate of change in there
then you can say uh you know you have
zero
as far as your derivative derivative is
concerned mathematically
and what that does is allow you to treat
that whole thing from
a visualization point of view as if
nothing moved
okay because there's no change in the
rate no rate of change
that's the notion in general okay and so
one of the guys who picked up on that
was uh richard feynman
okay and how what did he do well
if if you take the classical uh path
integral
you just take a ball going from a to b
and you say well it went straight okay
we're done okay
but in quantum according to quantum
because of the uncertainty principle
the ball and we're talking about again
a uh a quantum ball okay
so keep that in mind what was a ball is
an equation it's a
probability wave or a probability
function or whatever they want to call
it it's a number okay
but they're going to treat it as a ball
that's where the
that's where the trick comes in and what
they do is they have this ball that
goes from a to b but according to
quantum because of the
uncertainty principle that ball goes
through every
possible itinerary
trajectory that you can imagine it goes
through all of them
it's not that it can go it's that it
does go a particle goes from a to b
through all these itineraries through
all these
paths and you say okay
let's concede that i don't know how what
kind of sense that makes
but uh is that what you say okay and so
what's what's the deal and what feinman
supposedly
invented came up with he said look we
can treat that also
as a single uh integral and the way they
do that
is some of these paths cancel out for
different reasons like you know you have
destructive interference okay you have
also
you look at the most relevant paths
again very selective they say well you
know that one that went throughout the
universe what's the chance
what how much does it contribute
to our real probability of that particle
going from a to b and they say well very
little
negligible uh infinite decimal
how about nothing and so they reject
those points
those outliers they just get rid of all
that and they calculate you know
uh an integral for that path and they
can't come up with
uh what they think is or what they
propose is the wave function okay which
tells you how particles move in the
quantum world essentially
okay so so this is where where his
revolution came in
because what's he really doing he's
going to treat all this
um and they do to this day they're going
to treat it as a wave extended wave it's
no longer a
concentrated particle until you measure
it but between that
they say well it's it's a wave it's a
field and what is a wave
what is a field well it's not like a
wave is something that travels
they treat they're going to treat it a
little differently they say it's
extended
where is a wave where is a field
well the field is everywhere it's
the entire universe but locally here it
vibrates
and that's going to call they're going
to call that a particle
and they're not going to look at whether
it's a ball or anything like that
they're just going to
describe it mathematically and say this
vibration here that's what we're
concerned with
this is how much the particle is
vibrating here's the equation
so they represent the equation with a
vibration
of efficient locally and they say well
that's what that's your particle
if you can follow my train of thought
that's how essentially what they're
trying to do here okay okay so they have
this
this field is localized field which is a
particle
but at the same time the field is
extended or the wave is extended
and it's all over the place and that
comes in handy when you want to explain
stuff like tunneling which is another
subject i covered the other day
okay here is the notion of tunneling
okay
and the tunneling what they suppose he
saw or observed they claim they observed
uh
in the lab is that they they pass light
or an electron from uh to a barrier
there's a barrier an energy barrier okay
and it turns out that the particle
goes right through the energy barrier is
on the other side
and it does so faster than the speed of
light it does so
like instantaneously it appears it's
already on the other side
of the barrier is how can that possibly
how can the particle go through a wall
imagine throwing a basketball like shown
there
through a wall and it's on the other
side but it's on the other side before
you even throw it almost as soon as it
touches the watch already on the other
side at the same time
that's what these people are saying and
you say well that doesn't make much
sense
no it doesn't and here it is
what they do is they turn the particle
into a wave
or they can turn it into a field as well
they use the wave and so the wave is
already on the other side the wave is
extended it's already extended
on the other side okay so they they
claim that what they did here
is um throw a ball and then they have
this extended object that
already started it where the ball was
here at the starting point of the ball
and it extended
to the other side of the energy barrier
so there is no
time involved it's like all you got to
do is take an
integral there right path integral and
you get a number and that number
is already on both sides physically from
from their point of view from the way
they analyze this
physically it's already on both sides so
that's how they get through this
this little story okay that's that's
their story
okay and here uh you have another
version of tunneling okay
how did they do it these are the stuffs
steps if you want to explain tunneling
to someone very simple you convert the
ball into a wave or a field
that's step number one step number two
you tell the crowd
that the wave or the field is everywhere
okay
so now you covered all the bases the
play area is at four
bases at once in fact they say that you
know
uh quantum says a particle can be at all
places at once
and it is it's not that it can it is at
all places at once
and you say how can that possibly be
they say what's the principle of
uncertainty uh
heisenberg's principle of uncertainty
allows for it in quantum mechanics
it's the foundation of of quantum
mechanics particle is everywhere
and it's also localized it's only
localized when you measure when you
do something to it when you try to see
it or whatever but otherwise it's
everywhere
okay so this is their their explanation
so this is these are the steps you gotta
use if you wanna explain you know um
tunneling to
someone okay step number three clarify
that each ball
tracks its own proper time every ball
carries its own clock
so if you say well how come this
particle uh
takes a longer route and arrives at the
same time as this one which went
straight
well that's to you see to the particle
it's carrying its own clock
if it goes at the speed of light or
close to the speed of light or whatever
it carries its own clock and you have
time dilation and that relates
it to special relativity okay so that's
that's
that's what they like about it that you
can uh put all this uh
field theory this quantum field theory
you can relate it to special relativity
and there's a chance of unifying these
two
theories okay so this is why they like
it also
okay you apply the principle of
stationary action you know
moving while standing still or vice
versa and then the ball is now on the
other side
as a wave or a field in zero time
because the wave is everywhere
okay so these are the tricks that they
play and
they say well mathematically it's sound
in other words that's
that's what they're going to do they're
going to play with all this stuff
mathematically
okay and then when you when they give
you the uh
physical interpretation the physical
version
they lost you completely because that's
the part people want to understand and
you won't understand that
in the case of quantum mechanics it's
all irrational or like mr feynman said
uh physicists mathematical physicists
have given up on that
i'm trying to understand all that trying
to explain it or whatever
so they don't deal with that anymore
they consider all that stuff
um philosophy that's
trio's philosophy okay so let's get to
uh
where we are today okay so we have this
the instanton
okay and you won't find it in the
i mean it's a particle right pseudo
particle quasi particle
and where do you find it in the standard
model
of particles well you won't find it in
there
in fact there's a whole bunch of pseudo
and quasis out there
i call them queasies because they're
kind of crazy
okay and uh and you won't find them in
you find all these mentioned out there
and people studying them and
writing papers in the official
literature but you won't find it in a
standard model
so don't look for it in the standard
mode you won't find any
instant on there and certainly you won't
find a phone on okay
okay um and here
we have uh what these particles look
like
okay there's your classical particle
okay
i think we all understand that's a ball
you wanted a cube fine it's up to you
triangle
or pyramid whatever uh typically people
uh illustrate as a ball what does the
quasar or the pseudo particle look like
well it looks like that
it's an equation uh maybe a wave
function
that's the so-called quasi-particle or
pseudo particle it's a bunch of um
hieroglyphics mathematical hieroglyphics
and what does that have to do with a
physical interpretation with talking
about
balls going through walls turning into
fields and waves well it doesn't have
anything at all to do with that
the way they do it is they simply say
look this is the equation this is the
description
and that's what they care about okay
okay
here's the definition i guess you could
say
quasi-particle and
collective excitations that's what they
are okay
they are emergent phenomena
emergent phenomena what is an emergent
phenomena i've got a little definition
here give me a second here let me get it
up there
uh there it is
okay here's the definition of uh
what they call emergence or emergent
phenomena for those who are not familiar
with this
concept it occurs when an entity is
observed to have
properties properties they're going to
talk about properties okay not the
entity itself it's parts it's
its parts do not have on their own
properties or behaviors which emerge
that's why it's called emergent
only when the parts interact in a wider
hole
okay so that's the notion of the
quasi-particle it's a
collective excitation which is again
an emergent phenomena that occur when
microscopically complicated system such
as
a solid okay behaves as if it contained
different weakly interacting particles
in vacuum and here's an example an
electron travels through a semiconductor
its motion is disturbed
in a complex way by its interactions
with
other electrons and with atomic nuclei
the electron behaves as though it has a
different effective mass
traveling unperturbed in vacuum such an
electron is
called an electron quasi particle
okay so see they uh
they have all these uh emergent uh
properties and what they're gonna do
is they're gonna treat them as actual
particles so they're they're not gonna
talk about the particle anymore they're
going to talk about
these properties that emerge when you
have a collective
vibration or whatever of many electrons
many particles many atoms whatever
when they look at the whole thing they
say oh a new property emerged
and they're going to call that property
a pseudo or quasi particle
okay you see how how they morph
the language essentially you know what
they what they did was uh
take a concept such as a property of an
object and there's that's what they're
going to treat as
a ball as a particle as a corpuscle
and they're going to do that throughout
their physical interpretation when you
ask them when you finally
put them against the ball and say hold
on you're talking about particles oh no
no
in quantum there are no such thing as
classical particles
what we're talking about here is uh you
know
equations
that's the answer you get okay so what's
the deal with the phonon well the phonon
is also
one of these pseudo quasis okay
and again they had to create these
these uh little particles to explain
certain
motions of many particles
or many electrons or many atoms at the
same time
in the case of the phonon you say well
why did why can't we use
the same um you know one we use for
tunneling or for some of these other
things like why can't we use the instant
on there why can't we use
some you know the same particle over and
over and over
well they had to categorize all these
particles and in the case of the phonon
this is the particle of sound
yeah you heard right it's the particle
sound you wouldn't be able to hear if it
weren't for something for the phonaut
okay
you say hold it what do you mean sound
well again it's a quasi
it's a pseudo means that they're gonna
look at the excitation
of many particles in this case uh in a
crystal lattice
okay so you've had all these atoms that
form a crystal lattice say of a metal
or any solid for example and
they're gonna vibrate okay and that
vibration creates a
sound they're gonna call that collective
sound a particle called a phonon
okay yeah you follow me this is what
they're going to do here okay
so here's uh the fella who invented it
uh his name is
igor tom he's a soviet scientist died
already
i think that's him because uh it's the
only igor i could find
i guess he moonlighted in a frankenstein
movie and so there's your igor
the concept of phonons was introduced in
1932.
look how far back okay by soviet
physicist
igor tom okay the
name phonon comes from the greek word uh
which translates to sound or voice
because long wavelength listen to this
long wavelength
phonons give rise the sound
so when we have a long wavelength of
a phonon which is what an excitation of
many
particles vibrations uh they're gonna
say that that whole thing is a phonon
and without phonons we would not have
sound okay so now the
the the excitations the properties
of objects have suddenly become a phonon
and they're going to treat that as a
particle and they say well without
phonons you wouldn't be able to hear
so this is this is where the
metamorphosis occurs
where the concept suddenly becomes
something that hits your
ears or whatever vibrates in there in
your eardrum something like that
you try to imagine if you can the name
is analogous
and analogous to the word photon okay so
you have photon
photon okay see how they came up with
all this stuff
a phonon is a collective okay many
excitation in a periodic elastic
arrangement of atoms or molecules in
condensed matter
specifically in solids and some liquids
often referred to as quasi-particle
okay why do they refer to it as a
particle at all why do they use the word
particle
if it's not a particle is it to confuse
you to so that you think
in classical terms in classical
corpuscles
is that the point of using the word
particle to sneak it in there
i mean what is the standard model of
particles
are we talking about is the glue on a
particle is the
mu on a particle is the electron a
particle
or are these just equations what is the
standard model
of particles of quantum mechanics so
they use the word particle
which they inherited from classical
mechanics they kept using it because
they suggest or insinuate
that they're going to be dealing with
little balls when they're not
they're going to be dealing exclusively
with abstractions with
equations which they when they give
their physical interpretation they're
gonna
morph into particles they're gonna
insinuate to you who
don't care about the math you say okay
give me the bottom line you know i don't
know
how this particle got over there what
the trajectory is what it did
how it collided and they're going to say
well yeah it's uh that's when we treat
it as a ball
so here they're colliding these things
like in the
cern at the large hadron collider and
they're telling you they're colliding
they're smashing they use these words
right
smashing particles
and you say okay i understand that no
you know because they're not
they're striking equations against each
other
and the pie goes this way and the row
goes that way
a phonon is a collective excitation in a
periodic
set okay often referred to as a quasi
particle it is an excited state
in the quantum mechanical quantization
of the modes of vibrations for
clat for elastic structures of
interacting particles phonons can be
thought of
thought of as what quantized
sound waves well there is no physical
object called wave wave is also a verb
and again if you look at that transverse
wave that they always put since the days
of uh
james maxwell it's all vectors
mathematical vectors uh magnitude and
direction
that's all they are bunch and they they
put all these vectors moving on the
screen
it's very scary stuff okay so uh that's
what they are they're quantized
quantize sound waves similar to photons
as quantized
light waves okay so that's what they do
they reify all these objects
and what did we say at the beginning
that anytime you do a reification
of a concept into an object treat it as
an object well you're doing some
terrible irrationality in the the
discipline known
as physics
okay here uh so that you can see
what they uh how they illustrate this
stuff okay
and here you see a visualization of the
but the phonon is not one of those
particles or anything like that it's the
what you're seeing the effect the
excitation of all these
of the collective of the whole
neighborhood of particles right
that whole thing is called a phonon
and you would not be able to hear if it
weren't for the phonon what
particle so they turn all that concept
into a particle and now they deal with a
particle because that's how they do it
in mathematics they get a solution they
say okay this solution we're going to
call phonon
and now they're going to move that
solution around to
give you a physical interpretation for
what they're talking about so these are
different
modes of vibrations that that they came
up with
and each one of those different
vibrations is known as a phonon
so you got phone on one phone on two
phones three all these different phone
nuts
okay great stuff okay so it's fancy
stuff they like to look at these little
pictures and illustrate them they call
these
uh collective vibrations phonons okay so
that's what you're getting
for uh the money you pay these guys okay
that's what they're doing
uh here for you okay let me get this one
here's another version of this okay more
or less so that you can see it
and again an explanation vibrations of
atoms in a solid
can be treated as elastic acoustic
waves propagating through the lattice
okay so you have a lattice and
lettuce is like the side of
a uh or one of the lines that connects
two
um atoms in in a
crystal okay so you get you go in there
with your
telescope microscope whatever you see at
the atomic level well then what you've
got is one atom here another one there
and somehow that forms a lattice forms
the edge
of the crystal structure and what
they're going to do is going to tell you
about the vibrations that happen
all along this at the subatomic scale
okay so the energy of these waves are
quantized okay they're turned into a
little
ball okay that's what quantize means
quantum little ball
packet okay because the atoms are
discrete quantum
particles quotation okay phonons are
discrete
packets of vibrating energy okay there
you see it
uh you say what is the phone on the
little ball that's going up and down
no the phonon is
the effect is the motion of
all those particles that motion that
vibration that's what's called the
phonon
okay so now you know what a phonon is
you wouldn't be able to hear if it
weren't for all them
phonon particles hitting your eyes all
those vibrations okay
okay and um
so what is energy they say energy here
it is uh
this is what uh nobel prize finally told
us about energy it is important to
realize in physics today we have no
knowledge
of what energy is yeah because
energy is not a what energy is a concept
and so you can't say
what is energy now uh things we point to
and
concepts we define and he never realized
that
okay uh never never was taught that in
wherever he went to school okay okay and
because of this
you get to the next level where you get
people talking about
types of phonons like talking about
types of shirts or types of pants
well here's uh here's one fella who
talks about different
types of phonons optical phonons
optical phonon are excited easily
by light in acoustic phonons both
positive and
negative ions swing together okay so
there's a
physical or pictorial representation
of an acoustical mode how about the
optical mode bro
optical phonons positive and negative
phonons
swing against each other
okay so they have all these different
categories
of phonons which are simply by different
modes of vibrations
okay so so they get to the next level
when they where they start treating
phonons not only as particles as
discrete particles
but they began to move them around
categorize them
and do all these fancy things
uh one of the questions you should think
about today after
listening to all that well these are the
questions that i propose
to you for you to ponder okay
what is a particle that's the first
question what is a particle is a
particle
like these people say a pseudo a quasi
or a particle is the corpuscle of old
of the ancient world of the classical
world
is that a part i mean when someone says
particle to you what are you thinking of
are you thinking of
an equation or are you thinking of a
speck of dust a grain of sand a little
pian stanton
a p you know what do you think you know
well everybody thinks
a particle is a particle you know like
the little particle that's in your eye
oh
i got a particle in my eye that's what
people think of the word particle
at least that's my take i don't know
what yours you might think particle is
you know
an angel a spirit i don't know so first
question what is a part
okay and second one does an excitation
qualify
as a particle so you have a vibration of
whatever
could be water it could be the air for
all i care
you have a vibration of something so you
have a something you have a bunch of
atoms there they're vibrating
is the vibration itself uh
does that qualify as a particle can you
say that the vibration is a particle
which is what they
they're doing with pseudos and quasis
okay
is a pseudo particle a particle
okay so this is the train of thought
this is my reasoning behind this
i mean can we treat all this as
particles
are these real particles can we talk
sensibly
by converting vibrations into particles
vibrations of what of energy which is
even worse because you have vibration of
a concept
like saying oh we have the vibration of
intelligence we have the vibration of
love
and that's a particle if quantum
particles are not
objects things right if they are
mere concepts does quantum mechanics
have
anything at all to do with physics
okay what is physics is physics about
giving you physical interpretations i
mean these people are
just going to give me equations and
which are descriptions and they're going
to say well
we were able to describe something in
the lab yeah you were able to describe
it but
you know you're not able to explain it
you can't tell me what's happening in
that little world
and one of the problems that comes up
with this is what i mentioned the other
day
and that's that when you have
uh light interacting with atoms like
with electrons
well you know you can say that light and
even the electron belong to the quantum
world and we don't know exactly what
happens here we cannot explain it
fine but when it interacts with atoms
the real world you know like light
hitting your table
well you have to explain that
interaction now you're not talking about
the quantum world you're talking about
the interface between the quantum world
the one they can't explain with the real
world which is the one you see
touch measure etc
so now you had a problem because now you
have to explain that interaction
between the real world and this
quantum world which they've invented
okay and that's where they run into
trouble because they cannot explain that
interaction okay okay
so uh let's move on we're gonna do a
little bit of
questioning and answering see some of
the comments people made some of the
questions people asked
okay so let's go with that uh one fellow
okay he's been following some of these
things
for a while now put him on the uh you
know sign him let me get him up here
okay he says square is not an object
keeps insisting well until you define
what the word object means
we have no idea what you're talking
about
see here we define words and here i
defined it
okay here it is okay
what is this what is an object okay
object
is that which has shape okay and uh
there's a square is that thing in red
and does that have shape and
i would say that even a baby or a
kindergartner would tell you
yeah that has shape what kind of shape
well it's got squarish
shape good that's all we need that's the
only condition that we needed to
make it an object and so until you
define the word object we have no
idea what you're talking about you need
to define the word object
okay otherwise you know you're just
spinning your wheels
and uh yeah a lot of people do a lot of
that
let me get these out of here
okay next question here we have or
one fellow says uh
that he's got a better definition than
me for the word object okay great i love
it
i have a better definition object that
which has form
and location
okay tribal has shaped though can't be
real notice the words that he uses
and he tried by tri-bar triangle has
shape
a tri-bar triangle
can't exist therefore not all shapes can
exist
objects that exist for the purposes of
physics must have location
or else we can be talking about a 2d
drawing
so he's not talking about the word
object he's talking about existence
and so here's the homework for him he
wants to take
take it as homework object that which
has shape
if it has location we're talking about
something else we're talking about
existence
according to rational science exists
that which has shape and
location okay so
if he's going to say that an object is
the same thing as exists
his existence well then tell me what
exist means
tell me define the word exist define the
word existence
otherwise you have no difference between
existent object and that's the same
problem that
david hume and emmanuel kant had
that they could distinguish between and
everybody that came after right
i'm just singling them out no one could
ever tell the difference between an
object and an object that exists and so
we have to distinguish the word exist
from the word object okay that's where
the problem is
okay let's see if we can uh
get rid of this one
okay uh next issue next comment
fellow says uh let me get this here
uh if we're going to talk about physics
there is an actual dictionary we are
using the most popular one is
and is a dictionary of physics 6 edition
he said that a couple weeks ago
okay that's where his discussion started
okay so uh what came next well uh
this is what came after that uh
i guess was the last week or whatever
uh physics definition of object okay so
he has
he says he took this out of a scientific
dictionary he says
identifiable collection of matter which
may be constrained by an
identifiable uh boundary okay
that was his definition he says he
pulled that out of a dictionary uh
scientific
dictionary okay when you look it up uh
you don't find it in scientific
dictionary you find it in the wikipedia
okay and uh
but he says you can simply google
physics definitions
okay and an object has to be
three-dimensional he says a rock
is an object that doesn't experience
existing a circle square triangle are
not
objects or concept we call them geometry
blah blah blah
shadow is a two-dimensional geographical
those are examples okay so
so far we only we don't have a
definition that he can defend
because you got to defend your
definition even if you took it out of a
scientific dictionary it turns out that
you know when you look it up you find
out that he got this not from a
scientific dictionary
he got it from the wikipedia because
there you see it an identifiable
collection of matter
and let me put his definition again in
here see if i can find it
okay identifiable collection of matter
where did he get that he got it from the
wikipedia he didn't get it from a
scientific dictionary
uh and then none of the other ones that
he gave
our definitions they were all examples
okay and when googling the definition of
object for physics we find
again you find the one in the wikipedia
you won't find one that you'll find in
hub pages you see there the uh
link and if you go there it's the same
definition i have essentially with this
fellow put in there
and object then you have bozeman science
another one that's uh
you'll find on the in youtube there's
the link
and it's an object anything that has no
internal structure
okay so that's what he put but again he
could not
this file could not defend his
definition
okay and so what does this fellow
reply to that he says well he says
wikipedia the definition of object
doesn't originate from there
well i don't care where it originates i
think you got it from there i don't
think you got it from a scientific
dictionary because again
you cannot put a link and he says uh
youtube doesn't isn't letting me post
links so you have to do your own search
well you can put a link you just have to
spread it out i mean i put links and i
have no problem putting links in other
people's places but assuming you do
no problem just separate it like that
separate the h from the ttps and
and you can put the link we'll figure it
out now if you couldn't do that uh well
i guess you're not smart enough okay and
um
so he says it's definition of object
that which has shape
that is irrational well you have to
define what irrational means see we
define irrational here so we can tell
you whether you're
irrational or not if you're going to
accuse someone of being irrational well
you got to define it irrational and if
you can't do that you said nothing
okay and then the uh he continues it
says the first priority in phys
in the physics definition of objects is
that it is three-dimensional
well until you define the word object we
will not know
okay we will not understand what you're
talking about in a collection of matter
you haven't said anything because you
know we don't know if that's
three-dimensional two-dimensional
non-dimensional
okay you have again uh these people in
quantum they consider that
matter is made of nothing
so whatever you said by collection of
matter we have no idea
again you got to defend these
definitions it's easy to copy
uh you know just copy from the wikipedia
and put it in there so this is a
scientific definition
well even if it were so uh please defend
it
okay and we do attack that definition
and
attacked it several times you gotta
address the uh
issues that i raise against it if you
can't address them all you're doing is
putting your tail between your legs and
running away you're eluding
the questions and we we here we attack
the bull by the horns we don't
escape uh anyone who wants to challenge
the
definition of the word object hey we'll
tackle you no problem
okay shape is the only universal
property that all objects have there is
no other
universal uh property and again he who
doesn't like it only has to define the
word object then he can begin
his his defense okay he's got to defend
his definition
okay another fellow he says the
following he says
uh the something from nothing and vice
versa irrationality of the mainstream
exists in bill's hypothesis as well
oh okay let's find out bill's threads
must
bend to form ropes and atom okay for one
piece
for a one piece 3d thread to bend it
must stretch
and compress okay to stretch it must
create new matter
and to compress it must destroy existing
matter
a one-piece rod tell us how it could
bend without distorting itself alright
okay uh first let's show that okay
um here's a
rubber band and i stretch it i bend it
did i create new matter
okay so here it is i'm stretching i'm
doing whatever i want with it
did i create new matter okay so
that's the first thing you need should
keep in mind see if that makes sense to
you
but it turns out someone answered for me
you beat me to it kind of
and the foul says the following this is
another father who answered if i can get
this thing
in there
okay and let me put it over here
fella says the following uh he answered
this first vowel he said the thread is a
single object and it bends
you don't need to do anything any
creating or destroying of matter and
again i showed that with a rubber band
we're not creating new matter and we're
doing everything we want with it you can
do that with water also you can move it
all around you're not creating any
matter you're just moving atoms around
you are just confusing a fundamental
continuous object with a
an object made of smaller parts that
move closer to each
other or create gaps between them you
saying that you're saying part of the
thread can curve
into itself this is you thinking the
thread has parts that can curve
into itself okay so yeah those are
all very good uh uh topics
or answers that fellow gave them there
but uh
let's go a little further here okay
let's uh show where the problem is in
reasoning of the first fellow
all right and um
so let's go step by step here we have a
rubber band okay and we stretch it
okay so we stretch the rubber band kind
of like what i did just now okay
you're gonna stretch it there okay we're
gonna do that
we created no new matter okay first of
all okay
but uh what is he saying uh he's saying
well here well in there you have the
curved rubber band same thing okay which
is what he said
one part okay and here i'll show it in
more magnification so that you see what
this guy was referring to
okay and he says the following he says
uh looks like this like you know the
inside
is compressed the outside is extended
that's what he was talking about
and no you don't have to create new
matter in
our real world in a rubber band for
example but he's
he's raised an important issue let's
let's face it
he says look but if you say that the
thread
the universal thread that underlies all
matter is
made of a single piece
then now we have a different situation
because in the case of
a rubber band what you have is the atoms
are kind of getting farther which is
what this fellow
other fellow answered they're getting
farther away from each other and closer
depending on you know the angle and so
on okay so
we're dealing with the same atoms but
they're just stretching or getting
farther away or whatever
whichever way you want to explain that
in the micro world okay
but in the case of the thread this well
is right if you're going to bend that
and it's made of a single piece if you
bend that you're creating matter
from the void okay because
the top part is going to be extended the
bottom part is compressed
and if it's not made of little pieces
then in the top part at least you seem
to have created matter or maybe you
could even argue that the matter from
the bottom
somehow shifted to the top which again
means that it's made of parts
okay that's not made of a single piece
because if it's made of a single piece
you would think
right you would think that the bottom
compressed matter out of existence the
top part
extended and created matter from
space from vacuum from nothing okay
so that's that's his argument okay so
let's understand the argument first okay
okay so let's uh uh look at
how we're going to answer that okay i
think it's an important issue to answer
okay and here's a rubber band
rubber band is made of atoms so
here you have this rubber band again and
uh
in there it looks like that there's got
gazillions of atoms in there
and they move around etc they get
farther away closer to each other
okay that's uh that's how a rubber band
is so let's go step by step here
okay and uh here
here under the rope model you can see
how we do that in the
even in the world of atoms okay so far
we're still in the world of atoms here
okay
we have the rope hypothesis uh atoms are
made of threads the same threads that
make the rope
and i create the distance between them
because the rope the atoms slide along
the ropes okay
and so the at the the
threads when they get to the atom they
open up they form part of the atom
momentarily as the
atom slides towards another or gets
farther away
so the atom is sliding along the ropes
okay
and the threads are absorbed and then
released
absorbed in the front released in the
back you could say okay so the
ropes essentially over the threads the
two threads that form the rope
essentially slide over our atom as the
atom moves towards another
that's the notion that's the theory okay
that's how we're going to explain that
okay
but again here we're talking about parts
and israel is saying if you have a
single piece
how are you going to explain bending you
got to create
new matter and down here you you know
where
where you have shorter distance you have
compressed matter
out of existence because it's a single
piece
it's not made of parts you got to keep
that in mind okay it's very hard to keep
that in mind sometimes people lose track
of that so this guy's
on the right track there okay okay here
we have two situations and i can't think
of a third one
okay and i'm gonna put that as
questionnaire at the end okay
here you have a single piece thread and
you have a
segmented uh thread
made of discrete particles okay
now i can't think of a third uh option
it's either made of a single piece or
segmented made of discrete particles
i don't think there's a third category
but that's
for smarter people than me uh to come up
with okay so that's
that's the starting point but this guy
is saying if it's made out of a single
piece it can't bend
because otherwise you're creating matter
from the void
so does that mean that it's going to be
segmented is that what he's proposing in
the alternative
and if not what's the third option okay
that's where we're at okay we understand
that either you make it of a single
piece and you're going to bend it
without creating new matter
or you do particles
you're doing kind of like the quantum
thing you're you're going to have all
these discrete particles okay that
make up the thread if you're going to
propose the thread okay
because you've got to explain how the
thread bends and so on without creating
matter
new matter okay so where's the problem
well you
i say that you create many more problems
with the bottom
scenario than you do with the top here's
the bottom scenario okay
you have all these particles and you can
explain
light on light you can explain how uh
one thread goes through another
or ropes if you want and it doesn't
matter
how one object goes through another if
it's made of particles
discrete particles because all you do
what they have in in their minds is that
the spacing between two particles is
what goes through the spacing between
two other particles
for some reason you know the red balls
don't collide against the yellow balls
they
they just happen to match in such a way
that
space goes through space that's how
they're going to explain this
i suppose because otherwise you know
they have to explain this
you know i cannot imagine it in any
other way that what they're
talking about is space going through
space gap going through
gap okay but we created a monster here
a bigger monster than the one that i'm
proposing made of a single piece because
what
here we have this situation and i want
to go step by step so people understand
what the issues are
okay these are the problems
okay and i call it the principle of
single piece
okay in our macro world we have
no entity that is made of a single piece
there's nothing you can come to me from
a hardware store from from
a food store from anything that you can
imagine
air water liquids gases
whatever comes to your mind we have
nothing that is made
of a single piece no physical object
that is made of a single piece
okay uh so everyday matter is made of
parts
atoms okay therefore we have no
object in our everyday experience to
compare mother's nature's continuous
thread
against so if mother nature has a single
thread there
with which he does everything it's made
of a single piece
we would have no way in our real world
to imitate that could not be able to
imitate it for example with
with this uh i can say that the shape of
the thread is like this and that's about
where the
analogy ends but i cannot say that the
thread is for example like a rubber band
or
a string a closed loop string or
whatever
because all this is made out of parts
made out of
segments out of individual atoms
and so and according to the rope model
it stretches because again the atoms
slide back and forth
while maintaining this tension okay
so we have nothing in our real world
with which to
mimic mother nature's uh
single thread made of a single piece
if that's what she has out there because
we have nothing in our uni
in our macro world with which we can
imitate
or simulate that single piece
uh thread which is malleable
and a malleable part we can set aside
but we have no way of
of simulating single piece
because we have nothing that is made of
a single piece in our real world
okay so we have no object with which we
can simulate light or gravity
or magnetism and here's the two coral
areas the there is no
evidence that single piece is equal to
rigid
in our macro world because even when you
take
a steel beam just to mention one
item that we typically associate with
rigidity
if you take a steel beam you can stand
on it jump on it yeah there is
motion in there we don't notice that but
yeah there is motion in the molecules
and the atoms in there
but that's what we call rigid we say the
steel beam is rigid
but that steel beam is made of parts
and we call it rigid so the rigidity of
our world
cannot be extrapolated to the rigidity
of mother nature's world or vice versa
you cannot
extrapolate uh the malleability
mean meaning that it's made of parts to
mother
nature's world where she has a single
thread which is malleable
but it's made of a single piece because
we have no way of simulating that
not with anything that we know of in our
real world in our
macro world okay corollary number two
experiments will not tell you what light
is
again because uh and here are the
questions let me get to the question so
that you know what the homework is
if you really want to challenge what i
just said here it is
you have the questions okay
you get it down here issues to be
resolved
is there a third option beyond
continuous or discrete
slash segmented so
for those who propose the thread
you have to determine whether it's
segmented made of parts
or a single piece there there is no
as far as i know there is no third
option but if there is a third option
someone's smarter than me
hey come up and and show me what it is
okay
as far as i'm concerned it's only it's
either continuous or segmented
there is no third option so if you have
a third one let me know
does light go through light and let me
do a little experiment
people like experiments let me remove
this for a second here
okay i'll do a little experiment
just to show you
let's do it this way
i've got this light
press okay there it is okay that's light
yeah i go out of focus and here's
another light okay
okay so i have two lights and i'm gonna
run them right through each other
okay does light go through light yes
or no okay so here we have
light going through light as far as i'm
concerned
okay so what's the next
question or what's the next issue
let's get that back in here
light as far as i'm concerned goes
through light so you got to answer that
question does light go through light you
gotta go into these steps okay
if the is the mediator of light an
object or a concept
if it's an object uh we have the
definition of object that which has
shape otherwise you gotta define what an
object is
if you don't like that definition so if
it's an object it has
shape and light goes through light and
light is mediated by an object
you have to explain how mother nature
does that trick
how does light go through light and yeah
you won't find
anything in our world
any macro object that goes through
another macro world
object because if if you take
i don't know string and you run it
through another string or i can do it
here with
with rubber bands okay they don't go
through each other
they they hit each other away okay they
can't occupy the same space
so if light goes through light as i just
showed unless you have a different
explanation or a
different description or assumption or
whatever
if light goes through light and if light
is mediated by
a an object what is an object that which
has shape
unless you have a different definition
that you can defend
then we have to assume that this object
that mother nature uses
as a mediator for light goes through
the other object that mother nature uses
to mediate light we have two lights one
going through each other they're both
objects they're both have shape and one
goes right through the other
and there is no other way to explain it
other than that
you have a continuous entity that has
the property
the property the attribute the
characteristic
that it can go through itself
we don't have anything like that in our
macro world but you have to explain
light on light you have to explain
gravity and gravity
you know uh the moon
is that a good example
we can use almost any example there uh
we have jupiter
is tied somehow you know gravitationally
to the sun and it turns out that
sometimes in their the path of that
gravity interferes with that of the
earth and the moon
with respect to the sun so the
gravitational attractions kind of
mix or interfere with each other when
when they're aligned more or less
on the same axis and so
gravity goes through gravity also
because
jupiter doesn't care if the earth gets
in the way it does in the sense that
the earth adds to the gravitational
attraction at that moment in time
but it's not like because the earth got
in the way jupiter flies away or
pluto flies away no no it's like it's
just if anything it just adds it's like
gravity goes right through the earth
for pluto the gravitational attraction
of pluto to the sun
goes right through the earth whether the
earth is there or not
the only thing the earth does is add to
the gravitational
attraction it doesn't interrupt it in
and pluto flies away
you understand what i'm saying so light
unlike gravity on gravity
magnetism and magnetism you gotta
explain that
you gotta explain these things how how
you can pass your hand right through
magnetism
is magnetism mediated by a physical
object meaning that which has shape if i
can run my hand right through two
magnets
when you're pulling on each other you
know you feel the tension there and i
can run my hand right through it without
any problem
nothing stops my hand and so
is magnetism mediated by an object yes
or no and if you say no
well then what is it mediated by by what
you know what what is this magnetism
stuff that's in there
is it an object does it have shape or
not whether we can see it or not or
touch it or not
that's the question you got to answer in
physics okay
and so um is a mediator of light an
object or a concept and again you can't
use
concepts because concepts you can't move
concepts around you can't use them in
physics to say
energy did this and a field did that and
ether did the other thing you can't use
concepts as mediators which is what
everybody out there and their mothers do
even to this day
if the mediator of light is discrete
okay
the quantum ether okay
uh
what i wanted to say really is the
mediator light
discrete okay again is it segmented
and then if it's segmented well how does
one
particle or whatever segment pull on
another
affect another if they're separated by
space how does the
particle influence another particle
whether push or pull
remember because why would it be moving
in that direction if it does move in
that direction
why do they affect the one on the other
end
so particles have a problem because you
have no way of
showing physically of imagining or
visualizing
how a particle affects another from a
distance and they're separated by
space i don't care i'll just magnify it
as much as possible to show that they're
a mile away from each other
as long as they're not touching you have
no way of showing you how one particle
affects
another especially pull how does one
particle pull on another
and that's the problem with quantum
mechanics and all of mathematical
physics they cannot explain the force of
pull because they never discovered
elongated entities
invisible intangible elongated entities
if the thread is segmented how does each
segment
influence its neighbor so those are the
questions for anyone who wants to tackle
the problem
okay so it's easy to talk and say ah
bill you know
you're you can't explain how matter is
created we don't create matter
by bending the thread because the thread
is like this
uh rubber band in the sense that it
doesn't have to create
matter from the void it just has the
ability to be flexible
even though it's made of a single piece
which people so
typically associate with rigidity in our
world
but it turns out that the rigidity of
our macro world is made of parts
and it's not rigid you take the most
rigid stuff that you can think of and
it's moving
it's not rigid okay so we don't have
rigidity
or single piece in our universe in our
macro world
and so you know until you get your
brain around the fact that you know
mother nature has
a single piece malleable entity
uh you know you're going to have a
trouble you're going to have trouble
understanding
how mother nature does her tricks okay a
couple more issues here
there were several uh
well says so what is your explanation
for why light slows down
in a transparent medium well uh the
explanation is that you know
light never slows down okay light always
travels at little c at 300
000 kilometers per second and light
consists of torsions
okay 3d wave propagating along a dna
like medium that
interconnects any two atoms and so how
do we explain
so-called change of velocity which is
what quantum says
happens well here we do it with a prism
and we showed the differences between
mathematical physics
and what we propose here we have it okay
you have
uh you have if you do it with waves
and you do it with particles what you
have is one way
mechanisms they go they all travel in
one way
and what we're saying is there's no
traveling the ropes are already
connected
from every atom in the universe to all
atoms in the universe
so all we have is locally in this case
we have a torsion coming in white light
and
what the uh prism does to lengthy to
explain all the details here
but what the prism does is break it up
into different wavelengths
and frequencies
what is wavelength and frequency well
what you're talking about
is link links the links that make up the
rope
either they're elongated or short okay
these are
you have short links or long links and
there you have the equation the wave
equation
is the way is the equation of a rope uh
what we're saying is that when the links
are long you have
fewer links and when you have many links
the link links the links of links are
short
that's what we're saying okay and that's
why we have colors colors are simply
different
link lengths of the rope okay so it's a
different
model all together do you believe in the
model
we don't care we don't care we explain
the model so that you understand it
you reach your own conclusions in
your own dark basement okay this is not
sunday school this
is physics we explain we give you a
mechanism that you can sink your teeth
into
you can compare and then you reach your
own conclusion that's the way science
should work not the way it is now where
people talk about proof and evidence
and prediction and other and experiments
and observation i'm going to get to that
in a second
okay here's another uh fellow who puts a
comma says the concept of ether in my
opinion can be extended to the rope
hypothesis
oh my god if the hole is a single thread
then it has shape
consequently if we consider it part of
it in any zone
or region of the universe you know
without void or
of course universe plus zero equals
universe okay
which does not form an atom of hydrogen
for example then the threads and ropes
can be called
ether oh my god
okay let's address this gentleman here's
my answer to that
okay put it side by side so we
okay so why don't we just call it uh the
ether okay that's what he's saying
i guess he can't tell the difference
between a bunch of particles which is
what the ether
is and is has always been since the days
of the greeks
and anyone who talks about the ether
usually doesn't have the slightest clue
what the ether is they never defined it
they can never
tell you exactly what it means and there
are different notions of what it
what the ether is whether the ether is
fills
space or is space and those are two
different notions either space is a
container that contains all these
particles
that wave and create the weight of the
electromagnetic wave or the ether is
space and then in which case you got to
tell me what's outside of that ether or
does these are stuck stop somewhere
okay do those particles stop somewhere
and again you can see there's a
difference between the single thread
and the ether but why don't we call the
e the uh single thread god
how's that some people have proposed
that and they say oh that's god
well is the guy on the left the same as
the guy on the right
i mean is the thread the same thing as a
fellow who creates the universe
or why don't we call it space time i
mean that's a good way of calling the
the thread we won't call it the single
thread anymore we'll just call it space
time
they're equivalent aren't they i mean
are those two things equivalent the guy
on the left and the guy on the right
so what these people do is they they
they don't want to
release their the words that they
learned at the monastery
okay they learned these this word ether
and they've been brainwashed by the word
ether and they don't want to let go of
it like
the christian doesn't want to let go of
god and the relativist doesn't want to
let go of space time they say no no
i was born with space time i grew up
with space time
everything is space time and now they
see the threat and they say well
you know there's a different
interpretation we could call that space
time also
see because the thread has locations got
length width and height
and we have time and so we have four
dimensional thread
they can go on and on forever
you know it's like it happened to be
with some muslims
and they were looking at the koran and
they said look
the quran mentions europe i said what
what yeah you didn't come up with
anything new see the quran they found
the word
rope in some lost paragraph
some verse of the quran and is ah here's
the word rope so god already had come up
with a rope he didn't invent anything
now the quran already had it mohammed
already figured it out
and again is you can take that as far as
you want i mean you can say the ether is
is the rope you can say space-time is
the road you can say god is the robe you
can
it's nonsense ether means bunch of
particles
and anyone who doesn't like that
definition just has to define the word
ether
that's how simple it is and i'm sure i'm
going to be able to tear you to pieces
so please do not define ether in any
other way as
except bunch of particles because it
means that you have no clue whatsoever
okay so the word ether has to be defined
in fact i uh put up the
10 videos uh the other day so go through
them
so you can see my criticisms of the
ether
no one knows what the ether is anyone
using the word ether obviously
as to prop up their theory has no clue
what the ether means because ether means
bunch of particles
and there's a lot of problems with the
notion of bunch of particles
okay okay uh final issue
oh there's two well there's there's one
next to the last
and so this file says what how is it
possible to do science
without some observation how can we
explain gravity explain rabbity if
nobody is there to see the apple fall
oh my god oh my god okay let's answer
that question because lots of people
have that
what do you mean bill that observation
is not part of the scientific method no
observation has nothing to do with
science we don't know we do not
gawk in science you can gawk all day not
understand anything
you know you're not able to explain
anything
so observation is not part of the
scientific method so let's go through
the steps so you can put in the proper
context the problem here is context
let's go through the context okay
here it is uh the definition of science
let's begin there what is science
rational explanations where in there do
you see the word observation
it says explanation not observation not
prediction
not uh description it says explanation
so there is no provision for observation
in the definition of the word science
if you don't like my definition hey you
got a single recourse and that's
define the word science in a way that
you can defend it don't copy it from the
book because for sure you're going to
get it wrong there's not a single book
on planet earth that has a definition of
the word science so whatever they taught
you in high school it's for sure
irrational and i'm gonna
really beat you up on that so you better
be prepared to defend your definition
don't just copy and
paste okay okay and you can see
observation is not equal to science
okay did hawking have to ever observe
stephen hawking right
did he ever observe a black hole he was
the king of black holes right
and uh did he ever observe a black hole
do you need to observe a black hole do
you need to observe a photon
do you need to observe an atom in order
to
talk about it in order to use it as an
assumption in a in a theory
and what does observe mean in the
religion of mathematical physics
it means proof observe means i'm going
to shove it down your throat i have
evidence i've observed it what the guy
is doing is testifying he's serving as a
witness that's how it's the word observe
observation these words are used in
mathematical physics
so-called science they are testifying
they say i observed and if you say
you observe then how can you challenge
that if the guy's telling you
that he saw it with his two eyes or did
he see light
did he see gravity did he see the
mediator of
magnetism no he did not see he did not
observe like with the two eyes and so
when you look up the word the definition
of
observation or observe well then it gets
a little tricky because
they don't mean observe like with the
two eyes okay what they observe if
anything is the visible stuff not the
invisible stuff so mathematical physics
is
a hundred percent observation meaning
experiment and persuasion
what they're trying to do is shut down
your throat a theory saying they proved
it that's what the word observed means
but they cannot observe the invisible
they can only observe
the visible and then the rest they
interpret and they pass it off to you as
an
observation no experiment is ever going
to tell you what
light gravity is in other words
uh the only way to look at these things
is
to visualize them okay
and just in case because that's
related more or less here you have
uh the word prediction another favorite
word of the
so-called scientists out there let me
get these get back in here
okay prediction has nothing to do with
science we don't do predictions that's
astrology
okay so if you're into zodiac and
and reading poems and so on well then
you can do predictions don't bring that
into science okay
predict is not equal to science what is
science explanation
you gotta explain something you gotta
show that you use your brain what is the
predictions just a description
if you predict that tomorrow two o'clock
there's gonna be an eclipse
so far you haven't explained anything
all you did was describe give me a
description saying
tomorrow two o'clock there's gonna be a
um
an eclipse if i ask you why
now you're going to give me an
explanation not a prediction
what is an explanation a consummated
event you're trying to explain
what happened how it happened
why it happened and the only reason you
can do that is because you're already
familiar with the experience you've
already experienced
a uh in this case a uh
an eclipse that's why you can explain it
because you've seen so many of them you
have an explanation for why that happens
now you can give me an explanation
if you never saw an eclipse in your own
in your whole life
well maybe you can say tomorrow there's
going to be an eclipse the sun is going
to
be blotted out okay you can probably
predict that but when i ask you why you
say i have no clue
why because you have no experience with
it but if you have experience then you
can tell me why
perhaps right why the sun was blotted
out but now you're giving an explanation
not a description
prediction is description description is
not part of science
we do not describe we explain okay
so this is the issue and the reason the
mathematicians
like to talk about prediction is because
that's all they do
because it's description and this in
mathematics is 150 percent description
an equation is only a description you
cannot tell me with an
equation what light is that's why
mathematical physics has abandoned
explanations and calls that philosophy
dismisses it as philosophy oh that's
petting philosophy
and that's why we have no explanations
today for a rational
phenomena that happens out there for
real phenomena
and uh and that's what people want to
know people want to know why
you know this pen falls to the floor
what causes it to go down why does it go
up that's what they want and they don't
want an equation they don't want a
description yeah i know it goes down
that's a description tell me why and
mathematical physics answers well that's
not part of our
job description that's the answer
last issue
here it is fellow says
uh i would say that exists is that what
can be experienced
a dream is experienced so the dream
exists
if you wake up and the dream is over it
no longer exists
it no longer exists as a dream but only
as a memory the memory exists
bill will expect me for sure yeah
yeah it's like you're saying uh
you're saying okay uh
my great-grandmother exists see your
great-grandmother bill you're you're 68
years old your great-grandmother must be
what 400 years old
uh yeah she exists he exists in my heart
uh you know uh
but does she exist for you and your
heart your mind or whatever no she
doesn't
so so it's uh it's the notion of
ordinary speech
we've never defined the word exists we
just use and we say and everybody
says well i know what you meant by that
she exists in your heart she exists in
your mind you're thinking about her that
means
exists to me at that moment in time we
can't use that word
that definition in physics
in science so we have to distinguish the
notion of
ordinary speech of exist with the notion
of physics
physics is the science of existence
physics
only tries to explain what happened what
exists
what what happened and meaning what
objects exist
that cause it to happen so physics the
science of objects and physics is the
signs of objects that exist
okay and so the word exists belongs
exclusively
to physics uh if you say well now
in in church on sunday school we talk
about the existence of god
uh we don't care as soon as you mention
the word exist if you want to talk
rationally you gotta you cross the line
into physics
now you gotta abide by the rules of
rationality
and what is rationality you can't
convert concepts into objects you can't
say that
love exists not in physics not in
science
you can say that in ordinary speech in
real world
only objects can be said to exist they
exist if they have
location and with that i will see you on
wednesday we'll continue with